I am Kristen Goodwin on this episode of
the Fox News rundown president Trump
signing legislation imposing sanctions
on Chinese officials for oppressive
actions against the people of Hong Kong
New Jersey congressman Chris Smith
shares his insights on the escalating
tensions between the US and China human
rights abuses by Beijing officials and
whether he agrees with the Trump
administration's proposal to ban the
Chinese owned video app tick-tock in the
u.s. an immigration expected to be a key
voting issue once again this fall but
will the corona virus pandemic and the
economic crisis it's created change this
executive director of the national
immigration forum Alina Rani and former
Republican congressman Lou Barletta
weigh in on the immigration debate and
the future of daca plus commentary by
practicing physician and Fox News
contributor dr. Nicole Sapphire the Fox
News rundown is a Daily News podcast
where we take a deeper look at the
stories important to you you can
subscribe on your favorite podcast
player by going to FoxNews podcast.com
I'm Tom Shalu I'm Sandra Smith I'm Steve
Doocy and this is the Fox News rundown
Wednesday July 15th 2020 I'm Dave
Anthony the u.s. is putting sanctions on
Hong Kong adding two recent penalties
imposed on China which isn't taking it
lying down banning a few members of
Congress who have been exposing human
rights abuses you'll hear from one of
them but she's in ping in my opinion is
the ultimate bully and he does that to
countries he does that to individuals
and he does it to the weak is the most
vulnerable throughout all of China
through his secret police and his use of
torture
I'm Jessica Rosenthal is immigration
back on the agenda merit-based
immigration is code for this
administration say they're going to
slash illegal immigration but supporters
suspect presidential talk of executive
orders or even legislation won't veer
far off course the reforms the president
has talked about really stands up for
the importance of protecting the
American worker and I'm dr. Nicole
sapphire I've got the final word on the
Fox News rundown
the US is taking action against China
two ways President Trump has signed a
bill called the Hong Kong autonomy Act
allowing sanctions on any officials or
company's seen helping China with its
new security law aimed at cracking down
on dissent in Hong Kong the president
also signed an executive order ending
what was considered preferential
treatment for Hong Kong Hong Kong will
now be treated the same as mainland
China no special privileges no special
economic treatment and no export of
sensitive technologies the president
also said he's no longer interested in a
second China trade deal and he also took
aim at his Democratic challenger Joe
Biden's entire career has been a gift to
the Chinese Communist Party and he
attacked Biden on several other issues
hours earlier the former vice president
again took shots at President Trump over
the recent coronavirus search
hospitalizations and debts to the most
concerning indicators of Trump's failed
response are already unacceptably high
and they are rising back to the China
issue last week the u.s. barred three
senior members of the Chinese Communist
Party from coming to America over
alleged human rights abuses in Xinjiang
a province where the u.s. accuses China
of detaining and torturing wiegert's
a large ethnic group along with other
Muslims and minorities China called the
u.s. action interference that seriously
damaged relations and then retaliated
banning two Republican senators from
traveling to China Ted Cruz and Marco
Rubio who told Fox I had no intention of
traveling to China any time soon anyway
I didn't think they were gonna walk roll
out the welcome mat but it shows me I'm
actually proud of it no honestly I
didn't look for it but I'm proud of that
band because it shows were on the right
side GOP congressman Chris Smith was
also banned well I am planning to go to
China I've gotten many times I've led
Human Rights trips there many times the
New Jersey Republican has been in
Congress since 1981 and has been banned
by China before for speaking out ahead
of the 2008 Olympics the idea was they
were rounding up
all the dissidents the pastors the
underground Christian leaders and others
and putting them in prison so they
couldn't talk to journalists during the
Olympics so I went and raised those
issues and then they put a ban on for
many many years and now we seem to have
it again I do want to go back I want to
go to Hong Kong I want to go to the
shing Jiang where the Muslims are being
so cruelly mistreated by changing ping
in concentration camps and of course the
Beijing itself yes so this is something
I mean you have been dealing with China
and calling out their human rights
issues for decades now correct
I have Dave I've chaired 63
congressional hearings on human rights
abuse in China and in part of others as
well but chaired actually those put them
together and we've touched every aspect
of the human rights abuse to the
democracy destruction by previous
premiers and presidents of China but
nothing is worse except for mouths a
tongue then Xi Jingping he's on every
front genocide against the Muslims
completely trying to decapitate the
Tibetan Buddhist Falun Gong the
Christians the the Catholics everyone is
under siege there's that new security
law that went into place on the US has
certainly denounced that in a lot of
other countries have as well what does
that mean for Hong Kong well it really
means a whole lot of things but one of
them is that the the people's public
security police the the People's Army
now has a foothold in Hong Kong it is a
crisis and Hong Kong is not the same
Trump to his credit has called it out
for what it is he has imposed sanctions
both for the Weger abuse as well as for
the Hong Kong abuse so there's you know
they're taking action and I think that
Pompeyo secretary Pompeo and the
president commensurate with the problem
and but it's only going to get worse so
long as the rest of the world continues
to enable this as well particularly our
European partners of course Tiananmen
Square 1989 the world was outraged when
that happened and they used the tanks
and they and they and they killed
demonstrators what
is going on with the Weir's in the
Muslims no one is seen what is really
happening I talked to a lot of the
Diaspora here and many of the human
rights people who work in the Weger
realm there is a complete genocide
underway an attack on their faith a
change they call them re-education camps
they don't call them that but that's
what they are but they're worse than
that they're torture camps where if
somebody steps out of line does not you
know go along with the master they are
beaten and they are tortured and and
morkul Ruby and I had a hearing a couple
years ago we had a woman who was
horribly tortured in one of these
concentration camps a mother of three
who said she wanted to die she prayed
for death it was so cruel in this cells
themselves it was so tight that they
couldn't even lay down so they were left
standing for hours in two days and they
would take turns moving out so somebody
could lay down of course this is after
being tortured malnourished and
otherwise abused by the guards so and
that's going on every single day xi
Jinping is using you know the the
population control coerciveness that
they've had since 1979 no brothers no
sisters forced abortion against the
weekers as a form of genocide kill the
babies and there's no more ethnicity in
in Xinjiang because you've killed off so
many of them and the others you're
trying to completely change the through
this bogus re-education effort why
doesn't do UN get more involved why is
that the more outrage in the world about
what you just talked about in the with a
Weaver's David's a great question there
have been disparate voices that who have
spoken
some people have you know said a word or
two countries have said a word or two
the UK leadership has said more than
most where where are the leaders of
these Lama countries why aren't they
speaking out for one reason they're
being bought you know the belt in road
initiative which is a lot of
infrastructure money coming from China
is flowing to them and money talks and
then all of a sudden their voices go
silent
in order to get that foreign aid from
China they buy many many countries they
especially buy dictatorships President
Trump has been pushing for trade deals
with China saying we're not gonna let
them rip us off anymore but in this
process he's at times called Xi Jinping
his friend what do you have actually
done with human rights and what do you
want the president to do with human
rights as he works out trade deals well
it's a good question I wish he wouldn't
say things like that but that said his
administration unlike Obama I'm the
author of the trafficking Victims
Protection Act of 2000 is the 20th
anniversary of that law I'm the prime
author of it he put China on tier three
egregious violator and it was Pompeo who
really led the effort on that and and
and we couldn't get that under Obama or
others before him because they are
horribly trafficking women in forced
labor is ever-present in that country
the Hong Kong human rights and democracy
Act he signed that last December and is
implementing it the weaker Human Rights
Policy Act he signed that just a few
several weeks ago and it's implementing
that a matter of fact the global
vanevski Act which sanctions individuals
which is the proximate cause for why I
and the other three have been singled
out says we offer we provide person you
know individual person specific
sanctions for the worst violators and he
has done that now as well he did it last
week so this is kind of like a
retaliation I mean we're human rights
defenders they're human rights abusers
and somehow they say that it is somehow
morally equivalent today being the
Chinese government which is theater of
the absurd but Trump has implementing
those as well and I'm you know very
grateful that he's doing that I guess he
thought by being you know working with
cheesing paying early on that he might
get more out of it but Xi Jinping in my
opinion is the ultimate bully and he
does that to countries he does that to
individuals and he does it to the
weakest the most vulnerable throughout
all of China through his secret police
and his use of torture you mentioned
China using the you know
in China surveillance yeah in the US
president Trump is considering different
executive orders and one of them would
be to try to ban and shut down tick-tock
and I have to say I have an 11 year old
son who asked me this question yesterday
he said why are they trying to get rid
of tick-tock because you know he likes
the videos on there what he what should
it should we do that and why should we
do that
well I think we should and the banning
of that within our military I think was
a good idea the gathering of information
it's same way with 5g and Huawei and all
of the other ever-present means by which
they could gather information about
Americans and and know who you are where
you live what you're doing is it's the
surveillance state isn't just in the PRC
or in Ching Jiang or in Hong Kong they
want it to be universal and they have
the capability congressman tik-tok
claims it as a u.s. CEO us-based CEO
authorities I mean doesn't have any
norwich in China is what they claim it's
not stored there US CEOs for Chinese
corporations or Chinese majority or even
minority owned corporations and they
usually majority very often just go
along with whatever the Chinese
government says almost without fail the
President signed that Hong Kong
sanctions bill the same day Hong Kong
Disneyland closed again because of
rising coronavirus cases of course that
outbreak started in China and the
president has been criticized for hardly
being politically correct about it you
can go with the China virus you can call
it whatever you want to call it about 20
different names what they did to the
world should not be forgotten worldwide
there are more than 13 million
infections
about a quarter of them here in the US
the hardest hit country by far with a
record surge in cases lately that has
caused many states to either close bars
or other places again or pause reopening
and like the president congressman Chris
Smith wants more answers on how it all
got to this point
well I've introduced two bills one would
provide for a Blue Ribbon Commission
that would investigate the origin
and now and whether or not and I think
it's it's it's almost clear like the
nose in my face but still it needs to be
studied whether or not they willingly
deceived the World Health Organization
my other bill which I know really got
the ire of Beijing and that is to do
what we did
visa V Iran with Jasta the legislation
to allow individuals to sue in US courts
to get this first discovery and
hopefully compensation for death and
destruction or a loss of job or
especially related to health because we
want to compel evidence we want
discovery we need to get the facts
pretty soon the page will be turned and
the fact that you know millions of
people hundreds of thousands certainly
already have died and many others have
gotten sick lost their jobs I mean there
needs to be a consequence how did it
happen and the cover-up is typically
Chinese just like they tell you there
was no Tiananmen Square nobody died
there these infectious agents are are
you know unbeli unbelievably lethal and
look and look at the pandemic that this
is spawned I don't think it came from
that lab dude do you honestly think III
don't know for sure I think there's
there's reasonable speculation that came
from the lab or from wet markets or both
we want the truth why aren't we
guaranteed it and I wouldn't count on
the UN to get to the truth congressman
Chris Smith Republican from New Jersey
we thank you very much for your time
today Dave thank you very much for
having me on
[Music]
this is dr. Nicole sapphire with your
Fox News commentary
coming up remember when immigration was
talked about like a lot more since kovat
not so much maybe for obvious reasons
but immigration came roaring back into
focus in mid-june briefly when the
Supreme Court preserved daca in a narrow
five to four decision daca the deferred
action for childhood arrival program was
put into place by President Obama back
in 2012 it offered a measure of legal
protection to some 700,000 undocumented
young people brought to this country as
minors by their parents president
Trump's been trying to end daca but the
Supreme Court found the administration
basically tried to end it improperly a
lot of legal analysts and experts said
look all the administration really has
to do here is follow the Administrative
Procedures Act and show why they want to
end the program and then they can end it
but last week President Trump went on
Telemundo and said he has different
plans for daca kids I'm gonna do a big
executive order I have the power to do
it as president and I'm going to make
doc a part of it but we put it in and
we're probably going to then be taking
it out we're working out the legal
complexities right now that may sound
confusing but the president went on to
say he believes he's going to be signing
an immigration bill shortly as well one
of the aspects of the bill is going to
be daca we're going to have a road to
citizenship later a White House
spokesperson tried to clarify by issuing
a statement that said the president's
working on an executive order to
establish a merit-based immigration
system but that he also wants to work
with Congress on a legislative fix
addressing daca one that could include
citizenship along with strong border
security and permanent merit-based
reforms this would all not include
amnesty so is an executive order on
immigration and daca coming or a full
blown immigration bill in an election
year that protects daca recipients see
the reason I'm skeptical is that as he
was talking he's talking about kind of a
merit-based
approach to immigration he's talking
about an immigration bill
allene irani is the president of the
national immigration forum you know the
track record for the administration has
been that you know even when you know
the president was negotiating with
Senator Schumer senator
but 25 billion dollars on the table for
the border wall in order to get
protection for dreamers the president
didn't take that deal so the president
says that Schumer and the Democrats did
the did the opposite that they were not
willing to put up that much of 25
billion they were only willing to put up
I think it was a little over a billion
in January of 2018 Senator Schumer quite
frankly he was taking a lot of heat from
his base for making that agreement to
say 25 billion dollars for the wall
court to protect dreamers I think the
president was speaking about the budget
the ensuing budget negotiations that you
know came after the president walked
away from that deal so my point here is
that the president could say let's make
a fair trade here was protect dreamers
let's you know increase technology and
infrastructure on the border I think
Democrats they would be hard-pressed not
to take that deal
even now especially if it included a
path to citizenship like the president
wants to see that's what I was gonna ask
you yeah I was gonna I want to ask he
said he said that you know daca folks
will be included in a merit-based
immigration bill write that word merit
but it would include a road to
citizenship I think I think I heard some
immigration hardliners you know fall out
of their chairs when they heard the
words road to citizenship come out of
this president's mouth what was what
were you even more confused at that
point given the the merit-based
immigration bill talk because
merit-based immigration is code for this
administration say they're going to
slash legal immigration and you know
keep in mind that since koban 19 it the
u.s. the administration has put into
place almost 50 changes to immigration
policy now some of them have been
necessary for public health reasons I
would agree but - you know suspend the
htb program to stand suspend the h-1b
program there's no economic reason that
we should be shutting off parts of our
economy as we're struggling to recover
from this pandemic but what about that
for a second because I think some folks
would say you know maybe maybe now is
the time to put the American worker
ahead of you know giving out visas took
two folks to
you know even if the economy is
struggling and suffering and we need
workers maybe let's focus on building up
our own workforce you know during this
time especially with the the huge
unemployment numbers rather than
focusing on giving out visas to people
from other countries you know we do
think that we've got to assess in the
long term what our nation's immigration
needs are given this this pandemic but
when you look at a technology sector you
know this is a tight labor market folks
are being you know folks who are willing
to work and are able to work they can do
that remotely now and still these
technology companies are trying to
figure out okay how do they fill their
open positions and you know the
technology is not just your Silicon
Valley but it's also the backend for
your major retailers many major
manufacturers they're still in need
their food processing meat packing I
mean these are coming these are these
are industries that are core to keeping
the country you know frankly moving and
you know I think that you know the the
American worker and their families under
such incredible risk and stress at this
point do we really expect somebody to
move from Michigan to you know rural
Texas to you know work on a farm or at a
meatpacking plant I mean we've got to
have a better policy than expecting that
of of the American worker at this point
at the end of the day anything that
happens with immigration even if the
president is talking about executive
orders it has to come from Congress what
realistically can we expect do you think
in an election year either in in the way
of an executive order or or even
legislation which I'm highly suspicious
of you know I think we can expect more
executive orders on immigration I'm it's
clear that something the president and
his team enjoy doing and hopefully one
of those executive orders is to you know
continue daca protect protections for
daca recipients that would be wonderful
I do think that the legislative market
and is is unable to bear an immigration
bill at this point I think that it would
take a pretty heavy investment of
capital from you know leader McConnell
from speaker Pelosi and others to say
you know what we're gonna sit down and
hammer out
a compromise on immigration and that's
hard enough to do in an off-year hard
enough to do in a time when we were at
three or four percent unemployment I
guess a it feels pretty near impossible
right now now what about that phrase
pathway to citizenship the president set
a plan for daca would allow that but at
least one immigration hardliner former
Congressman Lou Barletta was not fazed
by that language well you know I think
that the president really wants to focus
on merit-based immigration you know
rather than a lottery system and and and
how you know allowing people to come
into the country illegally and giving
them a pathway to citizenship how it
affects those who have waited here
illegally and want to come here
illegally so the reforms the president
has talked about really stands up for
legal immigration and also the
importance of protecting the American
worker and not allowing people to come
here illegally especially at the lower
end of the economic ladder and have
their their wages depressed and that's
what illegal immigration does it
depresses the wages of the American
worker so I I think it's still going to
be an important issue in the campaign
compared to Joe Biden's open borders and
the Democrats open borders and you know
just allowing anyone to come into the
country and in effect the working men
and woman but he did say daca folk you
just referenced merit-based immigration
right he the President did say doc of
folks would be included in a merit-based
immigration bill and then he said with a
road to citizenship when when you heard
the words road to citizenship what what
did you think well you know when it
comes to to the issue of immigration
especially illegal immigration the devil
is always in a detail so you know I when
I was in Congress for example the gang
of eight which again in any group that
starts with the word gang is not really
a group I'm interested in but you know
the pathway to citizenship was really
amnesty so you really have to wait and
I've learned before you can form an
opinion on what what this policy
we'll be really need to look at the
details of what that policy will be so
it's impossible for me to comment or
anyone to really say what president's
thinking until you actually see the
entire policy that is he's putting
forward but I don't believe president
Trump is interested in amnesty
yeah but we're used to Prattville were
you surprised that with the language
given that my understanding based on the
Supreme Court ruling is essentially they
didn't rule on the constitutional merits
of daca they simply said look Trump
administration you did not end daca
properly you didn't follow the
Administrative Procedures Act and and in
so doing essentially the the analysis
the legal experts would tell you look
the administration could simply go back
rework the way it wants to get out of
daca show it to work essentially show
why proved you know prove that
procedures being followed and then
simply end daca if that's the case if it
would really be that simple to just
simply go back show your work prove that
why you want to end it and then end it
why not take that road if you really
want to end docket sounds like the Trump
administration and the President himself
is not interested in ending daca and is
in fact interested in broader
immigration reform well you know again
I'm not I'm not going to guess what the
president's thinking or what is his
total vision is for it so I think we
need to wait you know I'm not surprised
by language I wait to see what what the
written policy will be and then and then
be able to take that as whether or not
it's something that that you know can
pass or not okay Oh finally on this
particular topic a White House spokesman
got involved after the president's
interview and and sort of I guess some
have characterized what the spokesperson
said is walking back the president's
statements saying that he's working on
an executive order to establish a
merit-based immigration system to
further protect US workers
furthermore he has said he is willing to
work with Congress on a negotiated
legislative solution to daca
one that could include said
ship along with stronger border security
and merit-based reforms this does not
include amnesty what do you make of that
seaman sounds like that's sort of what
you what that sounds like a statement
you might have issued on behalf of the
president well you know I again worked
with the President on some of the
immigration issues and and and
understand you know again from his
campaign why he feels its own point but
it is a complicated issue and the
problem with with daca is is again
making sure that people are not able to
come here for example just right in the
last year or two and then use fraudulent
documents to say that they they were
brought here as a child so there's a
it's not as simple as as you know making
a couple comments and and and having
that become the policy we're now looking
at the details of of what daca means and
and how you protect people from using
fraudulent documents to to verify that
whether or not they've come here as a
child
former congressman [ __ ] Letta thank you
so much for your time okay it was great
talking
[Music]
getting schooled is a podcast hosted by
Fox nations abiona sack each week Abby
and her expert Jess tackle topics we
take for granted and help explain the
roots and meanings behind them subscribe
and listen now by going to fox news
podcasts comm america is listening to
fox news
Rayden review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
sapphire what's on your mind with many
respiratory illnesses specifically the
flu children play a critical role in
community spread also their younger age
equates to a simpler immune system
therefore they tend to be more severely
affected by such viruses the dynamic
between children and kovat 19 is complex
and far less understood however as
puzzling as it may be it has become
apparent that children can suggestively
play a lesser role in kovat 19 outbreaks
than other common viral infections not
to mention the far majority of children
do not become as ill if they do get it
although several proposed reasons for
this it likely comes down to two main
hypotheses children having fewer ace two
receptor cells in their respiratory
tracts or the necessary component for a
corona virus to enter the system and
also since the severity of code 19 seems
directly linked to the body's own immune
response children having a less complex
immune system may in fact be protective
and not only make children be less
likely to contract the viral infection
themselves but it seems they may not
transmit it as easily to others if they
do and this is an important factor when
deciding to reopen schools across the
globe where children who have returned
to school do test positive for the virus
it's far more common for them to be
infected by a family member
rather than at school Swiss researchers
analyzed data on 39 children younger
than 16 years of age and found that in
nearly 80% of the cases the illness came
from an adult in the house and that's
according to a recent study that was
published in the Journal of pediatrics
this data mirrors others produced by
China Netherlands and other countries
that have reopened schools although
virtual learning is a great alternative
when necessary
as a mother the three boys who are all
home during the stay at home orders I
could tell you it is not a long-term
solution and it is certainly not
equivalent to in-person education as
Public Safety grocery stores and medical
care could not stop childhood
development especially in our younger
children cannot either although much of
the evidence is limited on the viral
transmission amongst children since
schools and playgrounds have largely
been closed it may take reopening
schools for the picture to become clear
into focus within a month of reopening
schools it will be clear what the
transmissibility of the virus amongst
children and their caregivers is trust
me it won't be subtle and when we have
our children go back to school
invariably there will be outbreaks of a
variety of respiratory viruses including
colds flu and maybe even cope at 19
which is why we should consider creating
segregated bubbles throughout our school
system social circles and workplaces
should also consider doing this the
Washington Post reported on how Germany
has been able to manage clustered
outbreaks while keeping schools open the
German model creates what they call
classroom bubbles by limiting
integration among students and teachers
when a student or educator test positive
for Cova 19 that so-called bubble is put
into a two-week quarantine with remote
online learning while the remainder of
the school continues uninterrupted if
viral transmission remains high in a
community school openings will likely
fail mostly out of fear it would be
terrible to open schools just to close
them again the economic risk of not
having children attend daycare in
elementary school plus the developmental
risk to the children themselves is a
major public health emergency that
cannot be marginalized our children are
the future and their educators are the
frontline workers tasked with caring for
their well-being as a community we must
step up to lessen community transmission
and ensure the schools have the arsenal
of protective equipment they need
additionally local state and federal
services must guarantee the support
required to safely have our schools open
I'm dr. Nicole sapphire New York City
physician and author of national
bestseller making
get healthy again
you've been listening to the FoxNews
rundown and stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at FoxNews
podcasts calm and for up-to-the-minute
news go to Fox news.com
[Music]
from the Fox News podcasts Network stay
on top of the latest news and
information from Fox News listen and
download the Fox News hourly update on
your time the trending stories you need
anytime you want it listen and download
now by going to Fox News podcasts
dot-com love Fox News click the
subscribe button to get more of the news
and opinion you trust and click the Fox
news rundown playlist for the latest
episodes